acquiring the most powerful safety tools
for a better civil defense and police
promoting made in qatar and attracting
cutting-edge technological innovations
including in the fields of artificial
intelligence robotics detection and
prevention equipment safety systems and
services
that's what this year's milipoil expo in
doha is about the event meets a large
part of the growing security needs of
the state of qatar in a troubled region
qatar 2022 especially in the interior
ministries section presents the latest
technology and the latest systems used
to guarantee safety and security in the
state of qatar
since its launch in 1996 the milipoint
qatar has attracted the biggest players
in global security
last year the number of visitors reached
7924
more have been expected for this year's
edition companies and delegations from
40 countries are participating
one thing that is particularly
interesting about this expo is the
invisible presence of the qatar 2022
fifa world cup event it is actually on
every leap here we are a government
entity that
plans and maps out frequencies
what we are showcasing this year
is uh our readiness for fifa world cup
frequency management
and
licensing
for
local and uh international uh
bodies that require um the usage of
frequencies
uh specifically for the fifa world cup
uh time and sufficiency
as you can see some of the best
international companies in homeland
security and civil defense are here this
also helps us regarding preparations for
the fifa world cup
in this regard we have obtained the
latest equipment and the latest arms and
our joint training with other countries
are underway
one of qatar's most prominent partners
is the chinese communications giant
huawei qatar was the first country in
the middle east to implement the
the 5g
and that was in 2017 completed
successfully so you have the highest
quality of a network in the middle east
as we talk in qatar
it is huawei of course yes
allah says huawei is here again to
strengthen its partnership with qatar
and present its latest products scores
of other world companies in different
fields are doing the same
muhammad